I met mark when he was just blind I had
returned home to live in Dublin after
the Odyssey that was my 20s educating my
interest in human rights and equality
and university traveling the world like
my Nomad grandmother and during a
two-year stint working in Madrid dancing
many nights till morning and salsa clubs
when I met Marc he asked me to teach him
to dance and I did they were wonderful
times long nights talking becoming
friends and eventually falling for each
other
Marc had lost his sight when he was 22
and the man that I met eight years later
was rebuilding his identity the
cornerstone of which was this incredible
spirit that had taken him to the Gobi
Desert where he runs six marathons in
seven days and two marathons at the
North Pole and from Everest base camp
when I asked him what had led to this
high-octane life he quoted Nietzsche he
who has a why to live can bear with
almost any how he had come across the
quote in a really beautiful book called
man's search for meaning by Viktor
Frankl a neurologist and psychiatrist
who survived years in a Nazi
concentration camp Frankel used this
Nietzsche quote to explain to us that
when we could no longer change our
circumstances we are challenged to
change ourselves eventually I did
rebuild my identity and the why for me
was about competing again because
pursuing success and risking failure was
simply how I felt normal and I finished
the rebuild on the 10th anniversary of
losing my sight I took part in a 43 day
expedition race in the coldest most
remote most challenging place on earth
it was the first race to the South Pole
since Shackleton Scott and Amundsen set
foot in Antarctica a hundred years
before and putting the demons of
blindness behind me with every step
towards the pole it offered me a
long-lasting sense of contentment as it
turned out I would need that in reserve
because one year after my return and
arguably the safest place on earth
bedroom at a friend's house I fell from
a third-story window onto the concrete
below I don't know how it happened
I think I must have got up to go to the
bathroom and because I'm blind I used to
run my hand along the wall to find my
way that night my hand find an open
space where the closed window should
have been and a cartwheel died my
friends who found me thought I was dead
when I got to hospital the doctors
thought I was going to die and when I
realized what was happening to me I
thought that dying might have been might
have been the best outcome and lying in
intensive care facing the prospect of
being blind and paralyzed high on
morphine I was trying to make sense of
what was going on and one night lying
flat on my back I felt for my phone to
write a blog trying to explain how I
should respond it was called optimist
realist or something else and it drew on
the experiences of Admiral Stockdale he
was a powa in the Vietnam War he was
incarcerated tortured for over seven
years
his circumstances were bleak but he
survived the ones who didn't survive
were the optimists they said we'll be
out by Christmas and Christmas would
come and because
would go and then it would be Christmas
again and when they didn't get out
they became disappointed demoralized and
many of them died in their cells
Stockdale was a realist he was inspired
by the stoic philosophers and he
confronted the brutal facts of his
circumstances while maintaining a
fearfully would prevail in the end and
in that blog I was trying to apply his
thinking as a realist to my increasingly
bleak circumstances during the many
months of heart infections and kidney
infections after my fall at the very
edge of survival Simon and I faced the
fundamental question how do you resolve
the tension between acceptance and hope
it's not that we want to explore with
you know after I got the call I caught
the first flight to England and arrived
into the brightly lit intensive care
ward where Mark was lying naked just
under a sheet connected to machines that
were monitoring if he would live I said
I'm here mark and he cried tears he
seemed to saved just for me I wanted to
gather him in my arms but I couldn't
move him and so I kissed him the way you
kiss a newborn baby terrified of their
fragility
later that afternoon when the bad news
had been laid out for us fractured skull
bleeds on his brain a possible tornado
return a spine broken in two places no
movement or feeling below his waist mark
said to me come here you need to get
yourself as far away from this as
possible as I tried to process what he
was saying I was thinking what the hell
is wrong with you
we can't do this now
so I asked him
are you breaking up with me and he said
look you signed up for the blindness but
not this I answered we don't even know
what this is but what I do know is what
I can't handle right now is a breakup
while someone I love is in intensive
care so I call them my negotiation
skills and suggested we make a deal I
said I will stay with you as long as you
need me
as long as your back needs me and when
you no longer need me then we talk about
our relationship like a contract with
the possibility to renew in six months
he agreed a nice state in fact I refuse
to go home even to pack a bag I slept by
his bed when he could eat I made all his
food and we cried one or other or both
of us together every day I made all the
complicated decisions with the doctors I
climbed right into that raging river
over Rapids that was sweeping mark along
and at the first bend and that river
mark surgeon told us what movement and
feeling he doesn't get back in the first
12 weeks he's unlikely to get back at
all so sitting by his bed I Bank began
to research why after this period they
call spinal shock there's no recovery
there's no therapy there's no cure
there's no hope and the internet became
this portal to a magical other world I
emailed scientists and they broke
through paywalls and sent me their
medical journal and science journal
articles directly I read everything that
Superman actor Christopher Reeve had
achieved after a fall from a horse left
him paralyzed from the neck down and
ventilated Christopher had broken this
12-week spell he had regained some
movement and feeling years after his
accident he dreamed of a world of empty
wheelchairs and Christopher and
scientists he worked with fueled us with
hope you see spinal cord injury strikes
at the very heart of what it means to be
human and it had turned me from my
upright standing running form into
seeded compromise of myself and it's not
just the lack of feeling and movement
paralysis also interferes with the
body's internal systems which are
designed to keep us alive multiple
infections nerve peein spasms shortened
lifespans are common and these are the
things that exhaust even the most
determined of the 60 million people
around the world who are paralyzed over
16 months in hospital Simon and I were
presented with the expert view but
hoping for a cure had proven to be
psychologically damaging it was like the
formal medical system was canceling hope
in favor of acceptance alone but
cancelling hope ran country to
everything that we believed in yes up to
this point in history had proven to be
impossible to find a cure for paralysis
but history is filled with the kinds of
the impossible made possible through
human endeavor the kind of human
endeavor that took explorers to the
South Pole at the start of the last
century and the kind of human endeavor
that will take adventurers to Mars in
the early part of this century so we
started asking why can't that seem human
endeavor cure paralysis in our lifetime
well we really believe that it can my
research taught us that we needed to
remind marks
damaged and dormant spinal cord of its
upright standing running form and we
find SAN francisco-based engineers that
Ekso bionics who'd created this robotic
exoskeleton the would allow mark to
stand and walk in the lamp that we
started to build in Dublin mark became
the first person to personally own an XO
and since then he and the robot
have walked over 1 million steps bit of
an early celebration because actually it
wasn't enough the robot was doing all of
the work so we needed to plug Marc in so
we connected the san francisco engineers
with a true visionary in UCLA dr. Reggie
Edgerton the most beautiful man and his
team's life work had resulted in a
scientific breakthrough using electrical
stimulation of the spinal cord a number
of subjects had been able to stand and
because of that regained some movement
and feeling and most importantly to
regain some of the body's internal
functions that are designed to keep us
alive and to make that life a pleasure
electrical stimulation of the spinal
cord we think is the first meaningful
therapy ever for paralyzed people now of
course the San Francisco engineers and
the scientists in UCLA knew about each
other knew about each other's work but
as so often happens when we're busy
creating groundbreaking scientific
research they hadn't quite yet got
together that seemed to be our job now
so we created our first collaboration
and the moment when we combined the
electrical stimulation of Marc's spinal
cord as he walked in his robotic
exoskeleton was like that moment when
iron man plugs the mini arc reactor into
his chest and suddenly he and his suit
becomes something else altogether
seem on my robot and I moved into the
lab at UCLA for three months and every
day Reggie and his team put electrodes
on to the skin on my lower back pushed
electricity into my spinal cord to
excite my nervous system as I walked in
my EXO and for the first time since I
was paralyzed I could feel my legs
underneath me not normally
thank you it wasn't a normal feeling but
with the stimulator turned on up right
in my XO my legs felt substantial I
could feel the meat of my muscles on the
the bones of my legs and as I walked
because of the stimulation I was able to
voluntarily move my paralyzed legs and
as I did more the robot intelligently
did less my heart rate got to a normal
running training zone of 140 to 160
beats per minute and my muscles which
had almost entirely disappeared started
to come back and during some standard
testing throughout the process flatten
my back 12 weeks six months and three
whole years after I fell out that window
and became paralyzed the scientists
turned the stimulator on and I pulled my
knee to my chest you know this week I've
been saying to C Mon if if we could
forget about the paralysis you know the
last few years have been incredibly
exciting
now the problem is we can't quite forget
about the paralysis just yet and clearly
we're not finished because when we left
that pilot study and went back to Dublin
I rolled home in my wheelchair and I'm
still paralyzed and I'm still blind and
we're primarily focusing on the
paralysis at the moment but being at
this conference we're kind of interested
if anyone does have a cure for blindness
we'll we'll take that as well but if you
remember the blog that I mentioned it
posed the question of how we should
respond optimist realist or something
else and I think we've come to
understand that the optimists rely on
hope alone and they risk being
disappointed and demoralized the
realists on the other hand they accept
the brutal facts and they keep hope
alive as well the realists have managed
to resolve the tension between
acceptance and hope by running them in
parallel and that's what Simon and I
have been trying to do over the last
number of years
look I accept the wheelchair it's almost
impossible not to and we're sad
sometimes for what we've lost I accept
that I and other wheelchair users can
and do live fulfilling lives
despite the nerve peein and the spasms
and the infections and the shortened
lifespans and I accept that it is way
more difficult for people who are
paralyzed from the neck down for those
who rely on ventilators to breathe and
for those who don't have access to
adequate free healthcare so that is why
we also hope for another life a life
where we have created a cure through
collaboration a cure that we are
actively working to release from
University labs around the world and
share with everyone who needs it
I met mark when he was just blind he
asked me to teach him to dance and I did
one night after dance classes I turned
to say goodnight to him at his front
door and to his gorgeous guide dog Larry
I realized that in switching all the
lights off in the apartment before I
left that I was leaving him in the dark
I burst into uncontrollable tears and
tried to hide it but he knew and he
hugged me and said four-seam on your
back in 1998 when I went blind don't
worry it turns out okay in the end
acceptance is knowing that grief is a
raging river and you have to get into it
because when you do it carries you to
the next place it eventually takes you
to open land somewhere where it will
turn out okay in the end and it truly
has been a love story and expansive
abundant deeply satisfying kind of love
for our fellow humans and everyone in
this act of creation science is love
everyone we've met in this field just
wants to get their work from the bench
and into people's lives and it's our job
to help them to do that because when we
do we and everyone with us in this act
of creation will be able to say we did
it and then we danced
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]